Oh prepare yourselves today we take on
their thinker
what's happen someone's taking over our
systems still though I will cup small of
team flash steam is the only family that
I have ever had no one has to die iris
Caitlin Cisco Joe Harry
duo cannot have them
flash this Tuesday at 8/7 central on the
CW everybody it's Charlie we got to
freak out about the flash trailer and
also freaked out about the first look at
Titans Beast Boy Raven and Starfire like
we actually got a look at them on the
set of Titans in Toronto it is genuine
freakout mode so I'll talk about flash
first then I'll talk about Titans if
you're finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get all the DC
videos there's a new round of that blast
ring giveaway - I'll name a winner at
the end of this but it looks like
everybody is gonna get cut next week
including iris which is kind of nuts
because they spent all last season
trying to cut her up so you think they
give her a little bit of break but nope
everybody gonna get cut next week the
description of the episode just reads
when Barry and Team flash find a way to
enter the thinker's lair remember it's
in the pocket dimension
Ralph considers crossing a dangerous
line to defeat Devo meanwhile Joe is
concerned about Harry's recent behavior
which is just to follow up on that
post-credits tag where he's hanging out
looking like a berry season one you bard
Thawne Harrison wells now just to be
clear he's not going to turn into the
reverse-flash I made a lot of jokes
about parallels between those two
characters like he even considers just
like Thawne a couple episodes ago but
that doesn't mean that he's actually
turning into eobard thawne Harrison
wells
he's just juicing himself up with dark
matter like you can even see him in this
episode with like little speed force
energy juicing his brain the way that
the thinker's brain looks when he's
juicing the other metas and taking their
consciousness the line about Joe in the
episode description just implies that it
just like goes way overboard and he
starts acting extra weird so there's
really two different things going on in
this trailer footage though you have
them inside the thinker's pocket
dimension layer and then you have the
thinker in his wife using one of the
samurais inside team flash going after
them so I'm wondering if this happens
earlier in the episode like they breach
his lab then later the second half of
the episode is him coming for the meta
but this is episode 18 the title 4
episode 19 is fury rogue as in like
Captain Cold is coming back and they're
doing a Mad Max fury road inspired
episode where they try to transport one
of the spy
shall Mehta's preventing the thinker
from taking it in the process it's been
a little while since I've seen it but
they did an episode just like that way
back at the end of season 1 where they
were transporting a bunch of metas
captain cold was helping the flash out
but it was still sort of the evil
version of Captain Cold
this version is gonna be Leo snart from
Earth X so it'll be the same character
from the crossover coming back when they
say he has some sort of crisis of
conscience like he thinks about fighting
dirty against the thinker I think the
only big thing that elongated man could
do would either be to go after his wife
go after Marlies or he just flat-out
tries to do something that will kill
both of them instantly like collapse the
pocket dimension or just do something
this way overboard that will get rid of
the thinker but also cause a lot of
collateral damage remember the big twist
with Marlies where she keeps getting her
mind wipe so she's basically a prisoner
of the thinker team flash doesn't know
anything about that and she had that
moment with iris where she was being
honest saying that I'm trying to protect
my husband although they're doing
something very evil I think they're just
teasing out the team flash will
eventually find out what's going on that
might start to happen in this next
episode but remember how they plotted
out the last couple of episodes these
past few seasons usually there isn't
some big turn in the fight against the
villain - like the final three episodes
so if they are able to turn Marley's to
their cause against the thinker I don't
think it's gonna be for a couple more
episodes now we got to talk a little bit
about Titans and I know it doesn't sound
like I'm freaking out but I'm trying to
stay calm because I got just woke up you
know trying to process all this flash
information and all this Titan stuff
I've been tagged in like a billion
Twitter posts about this since last
night because the news broke last night
first look at Beast Boy Raven and
Starfire from the set of Titans we'd
already seen what Robin looked like so
him being on set isn't that big of a
surprise but what happened is is because
a lot of these live-action shows shoot
outside that's when the paparazzi get
pictures of them so that's how we got
our pictures of all these new characters
let's just start with the easy stuff
first then we'll wait in because they're
like you know series of like reactions
increasingly crazy as you see more and
more of the characters so Beast Boy in
Raven was the first pictures that broke
people are like okay you know kind of
looks like Raven kind of get it people
were wondering about Beast boys green
skin
I don't know if they're gonna tune this
green and he'll actually have green skin
walking around in broad daylight you can
see that Raven does not have the jewel
in her forehead so that's not something
that happens till she traps her father
Trigon in the jewel so it makes sense
that if they're gonna do a Trigon arc
that'll go across a couple seasons it'll
take her a little while to get to that
like if you saw the Teen Titans versus
Justice League animated movie they
basically told the terror of Trigon
story I've been using footage from it in
all my videos just because it's really
good for explaining the Seminole Teen
Titans arcs even though the actors
playing Raven is younger than the actor
playing Beast Boy you can kind of see
how they're pairing them up like them
just standing right next to each other
they kind of seem like they're close to
the same age and he's wearing his
classic costume as a jacket so if you
remember the Robin costume the people
that make the Berlanti verse TV shows
great Berlin see the arrow verse all
those DC shows they're the same people
making this so the same person that
designed the new flash costume are all
the flash costumes all of the arrow
costumes all the legends of tomorrow
costumes is the same person that
designed all of the Titans costumes so
like whatever they look like like some
of them aren't in costume right now like
Robin isn't wearing his costume Starfire
very clearly isn't wearing her costume
we'll talk about her in a second she's
really the one that people are freaking
out about so whatever they look like
during these photos when they're
actually finished with the episodes
it'll actually look much better it's
hard to tell just from the behind the
scenes what the show is gonna look like
like when you see the arrow in the flash
people on set behind the scenes this is
kind of what it looks like it doesn't
look very special but you get to the
final episodes and it looks way more
polished so just imagine what the arrow
verse shows that look like the show will
feel different the tone will be
different the characters are different
so their powers all work different but
just remember it's got like that same
level of polish that a lot of the
Berlanti first shows have and that
includes like Riverdale and all the non
DC shows that Berlanti does too but I
have absolutely no idea what's going on
with Starfire like is this what she's
gonna look like all the time because I
know that they've already done costume
tests with her inside this like big
scanning machine so we know what Corey
looks like when she's using her powers
but because most of what we've seen of
the character is in the
animated universe and there aren't any
budgetary restrictions so she's always
giving off this radiant light effect
it's sort of like firestorm that's
probably the best example I can give
within the arrowverse shows firestorm
walking around but looking like Jack's
most of the time that seems like what
they're doing with the Starfire
character so just expect that firestorm
to Jack's transition it's gonna be a
while before we get a trailer but I
would be willing to bet there are like 4
PR people at Warner Brothers freaking
out about the internet freaking out
about these pictures and they probably
have stuff that's ready to go like oh
you know you got this look at them
without any special effects you don't
know what they're actually gonna look
like an episodes here's like the shiny
version of them that looks really good
so usually when there are leaks like
this and technically this is a leak
because they didn't purposefully reveal
this but I think that they knew that
eventually people would get shots of
them shows like flash arrow are prepared
for stuff like this
so just do not be surprised once they
start to spread even wider like the new
sites have picked this story up first
look Beast Boy Raven Starfire that the
official photos of them drop pretty soon
I mean it would be the smart thing to do
they don't always do that but it would
probably be a good idea honestly I think
it's gonna be a little bit more like the
tone of arrow but with flash level
characters and special effects so you
sort of combine all the best things
about the arrowverse shows but hopefully
we'll find out in the next week but just
like let me know what you think about
this and what you think that they'll do
when the actual episodes come out like
are they gonna add a bunch of special
effects when they're just walking around
but what will happen is is they just
posted a whole bunch of new infinity war
footage I'll do a video for that next
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Israel Jimenez please private
message me so I can get your contact
details yes yes I did totally do a video
about the Titans pictures click here for
my new flash episode and click here for
brand new infinity war thank you so much
for watching everybody to stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight